babble commercial everyone likes the
babble commercial these alpha cucks out
there
these alpha cups just can't handle it
[Music]
thanks for joining us we have rachel
[ __ ] offer rachel hey thanks for
joining us today how are you i'm good
man a what an entertaining show you put
on tell me oh wow you know appreciates
that yeah well i i i try i try to make
them laugh i try to fire them up you
know yeah we got to do some stuff over
here we get we ain't got time to waste
which is which is why i wanted to bring
you on we've been trying to work this to
where you come on um for the last couple
weeks maybe you should come on like
every week and give us an update of
what's going on out there because you're
you're watching these polls you're
watching some of these things that are
happening inside um these races and
stuff and i've been talking about
strategic outrage here on the show we
kind of i don't know i guess i guess you
coined the phrase on the interview that
we had a couple weeks ago which if
people want to go watch that interview
it is on youtube uh you should go check
it out because not not only did we play
trivia but um we you kind of break down
especially in the second half after the
trivia this strategic outrage so tell us
where are we at on this strategic
outrage where
where are we headed here for 2022 what
do we need to accomplish with this with
this strategic outrage
yeah so you know just to recap with
everyone right we're talking about how
we're going to go head-to-head with with
a party that's declared open war right i
mean it's a it's a war that's been
declared on us we have no choice but to
fight it we can choose not to fight it
and do the appeasement route that worked
out great for the uk right so we're not
going to do that we're we are going um
balls to the wall and we're getting
people
into this concept of hey
maybe
maybe we should try some of these
techniques that republicans use because
believe it or not
we're all competing in in the in the
conversion pool for swing voters so if
fear
outrage disempower you know an emotion
is working over there i'm pretty sure
we can get people
uh motivated using similar uh techniques
getting people to think about a few
things and get really pissed off about
them that is strategic outrage in a
nutshell right a mountain making
mountains out of mole hills
about something like crt
right and you know they they turn this
one i mean we had people dying all over
the state of virginia
who were listening to republicans right
oh don't worry about it's just the flu
don't get a vaccine you're a [ __ ] if
you do right right right and like yeah
we let that [ __ ] campaign close out
on race in schools jesus you know so
strategic outrage is about directing our
angst to the proper channel the
republican party and then putting all of
this angst to use to maybe save
democracy because one of the things that
we're facing in this midterm is a
purposely strategically deflated
democratic base it was strategically
deflated by the gop's obstruction
strategy the purpose of that strategy
was to keep joe biden from giving you
the [ __ ] that you want so that you would
stay home in 22 and they can take over
the government uh so you know don't let
them win [ __ ] twice right not only do
you not have your child care but you
also you know are going to hand congress
back to a republican party that's
engaged in a massive you know you know
dismantle the rule of law
right [ __ ] them well you know right well
you know i've been talking about this a
lot on the show and even in twitter
spaces is that we have to stay pissed we
have to go [ __ ] vote and when i say
go [ __ ] you know because everyone says
stay pissed well it's not just enough to
stay pissed you have to go [ __ ] vote
but when i say that i mean go get
engaged i don't just mean mark a ballot
um go [ __ ] vote means that it's
contacting your your your county party
google it google the county that you're
in go engage with them engage engage
however you can with the candidates
wherever you can go to get engaged but
more importantly more importantly
democrats have to stop being scared of
politics and government i've been saying
this for a long time a long time that
politics and government are two separate
things republicans have understood this
for decades like they know that
government is one thing politics and the
noise is a completely separate thing and
the politics enables you to be the
government like without politics you
can't be a government and you cannot
govern you can't do the things to
legislate and administrate policies that
you want to have joe biden can yell and
scream all day long right but if he
doesn't have a senate or a house that
will pass anything absolutely anything
well he's completely [ __ ] what is he
going to do i mean he has he has the
power of executive orders but that's not
just not enough for what people want
that's kind of like the cancel student
debt argument but we can't get in the
weeds with every single one of these
line items on the bill we have to stay
focused and this is what they've always
done is stay focused on the the task at
hand to get to get to where we can
govern once we can govern we can do all
those line item things and democrats can
find out the details rather minimum
wages x amount of dollars rather you
start school with three you start school
at four
rather
what kind of college debt is eliminated
you know we can have all those
conversations but we cannot have them
if you have i don't know like steve
bannon the speaker of the house like
you're not gonna have those [ __ ]
conversations that fascists take over
this country right yeah and what really
pisses me off tony i mean you know in in
so far as like there are external and
and internal
like things right and the external [ __ ]
is one thing right but internally i mean
you if you're the biden team like
there's no political benefit to you to
pretend that you're governing in normal
circumstances okay and that's where they
were they totally [ __ ] up you should
have come out of the out of the
inaugural and said look this is i mean i
know what we talked about on the stump
but this i mean look what almost just
happened we almost just lost american
democracy we don't have an honest
opposition you cannot craft [ __ ]
public policy in the united states of
america with one party unless you seize
power and consolidate it and turn it
into an autocracy because our
system is designed in such a way to bite
purposely by furygate policy into at
least two factions two parties and you
know it's not a parliamentary system so
you don't get the coalitional stuff
going we we've got you know we've got
institutional constraints here guys and
if we want policy we ought to make it
really [ __ ] clear the reason you have
what you see in a earth that's on fire
isn't because of the goddamn democrats
okay it's not joe manchin it's [ __ ]
the republican party they killed the
earth then when they got busted and it
was clear that they that the climate
change was occurring they made a hoax
about it they paid tobacco lobbyists to
create an entire [ __ ] hoax about
climate change right and now they're
obstructing climate legislation don't i
mean manchester united well to own the
libs right to own
this is crazy because almost everything
that we're seeing even even down to just
this week with ukraine and russia i mean
they're absolutely 100 all in with putin
which is [ __ ] just
flabbergasting that one of our our our
[ __ ] major parties in this country is
putting their weight behind putin be to
own the libs or some [ __ ] [ __ ] like
what the [ __ ] are you people talking
about
do you want america in general like i
know we you want to fight about guns and
abortion and [ __ ] but like his goal his
goal is to tear down democracy and i
think that's the realization that we
need to come to is that there's a
certain percentage of the population in
this country that have been absolutely
convinced that democracy doesn't work
and that's why they want autocracy
that's why they've seen the golden calf
and trump and i mean they kind of
abandoned him a little bit but not the
idea of him right like there's so many
of these [ __ ] waiting in the wing to be
the next trump uh desantis and some of
these others really he's he's probably
up there right now as the top until he
probably [ __ ] up and steps on trump's
toes or who knows what they're gonna
battle it out dude i mean that's some
good [ __ ] right there right if you
really want to get into like some good
like uh you know war strategy the the
fight in florida right now guys i mean
that is good [ __ ] because you've got to
have some massive paranoia coming in
like is desantis actively working
against trump for that nomination is
trump working against desantis they
don't trust each other they're both
skeezy [ __ ] so they're no doubt
undercutting each other the whisper
campaign within the country club set
must be fantastic in that regard and uh
you know it's probably the only thing we
have going for us is that we've got two
uh you know uh aspiring autocrats who
want to compete for that party mantle
right now and that at least keeps them a
little distracted on infighting
well
right and i think i think we could use
that as a strategic outrage is to keep
them [ __ ] killing each other because
they do that so well with us right
they're like oh well are you gonna have
minimum wage at 15 or 18 an hour
democrats fight for like four four
[ __ ] months over three dollars while
they destroy every [ __ ]
uh
legislator and every piece of government
that they possibly can and we're like oh
what we turn around like what happened
we were arguing about minimum wage and
they took away all this other [ __ ] they
took away women's liberty in mississippi
and texas and like jesus christ
if if we can actually put wedges in
between these [ __ ] um that's part of
the strategic outrage too so it's not
just about getting democrats elected
it's about letting the [ __ ] sandwich eat
the [ __ ] sandwich right yep yep oh yeah
the more that we're talking every day we
ought to be talking about them dude and
i get hit with this [ __ ] all the time
because of the data science component of
my my uh you know my uh resume so like
oh well you know look at this you've got
you know the culture wars stuff is
pushing people away yeah okay well
number one there's like five [ __ ]
democrats that wanted to fund the police
in total like i mean rank and fight
across the [ __ ] so it's a made-up
it's still a made-up controversy right
and right you cannot control the other
[ __ ] side so you can tell i mean it's
not like jamie harrison in south
carolina or um doug jones in alabama ran
like they held those positions right
right mattered was the illusion the gop
created here we've got the best goddamn
clay you could ever [ __ ] hope to work
with because these people are
certifiably nuts they're stupid as [ __ ]
and and even worse they're all criminals
right you're right
right they're they're all having to go
into the january 6 select committee and
and and plea the fifth so they don't
self-incriminate themselves on federal
sedition charges and be tied in with
these [ __ ] proud boys it's ridiculous
oh my god yes and we've got the whole
like democratic campaign like world is
like handwritten oh my what do we do
about the narrative with the pandemic oh
my what do we do about like the five
crazy [ __ ] people in the democratic
party i'm like new baby you should point
out
right right maybe we should point out
that like they're [ __ ] crazy people
are in charge of the party and this is
what they want to do to you right right
right this is what they want to do to
you not to some nameless faceless brown
skinned person that they don't give a
[ __ ] about or you know whatever right
this is what you is gonna happen to you
under this gop autocracy because if
you're trying to persuade these you know
these myopic white swing suburbanites
that got afraid of their kids learning
about tony morrison in school you gotta
[ __ ] hit them where they are you
can't hit them where you want them to be
i want them to be persuadable by you
know hey we should not steal the right
to vote for um people of color but
unfortunately that's not how these
people think and that's not how anyone
really thinks i mean not to harp on
white white people human psychology
almost 90 percent of us is
self-interested right right right
deal with that self-interest component
and there's absolutely not one thing in
the autocratic gop plan
that doesn't impact every family working
class middle class you know giant middle
class rich middle class and up because
it comes right into your [ __ ] house
and it turns your kids into breakfast
nerves as we talked about i love the
breakfast i love the breakfast narcs i
love it i mean that's what they're doing
in virginia right here's a tip line
right right i mean dude
it's served up on a platter for
democrats right
literally nothing they can't attack us
for tony that i i always sit there and
say god i have i don't need anything
else some reporter asked me do they need
to you know overturn roe i'm like no
dude did they have to come and overturn
the second amendment to make a gun you
know gun rights ideological [ __ ]
interest group rich movement right to do
electoral politics no they just
pretended it was gonna happen right
right well they still pretend they still
pretend there's joe biden's still gonna
take their guns after obama took him for
eight years i mean this is all nonsense
it's always nonsense with them that's
why they love trump is because he played
to the house of cards more than anyone
could ever imagine that's why they they
got so infatuated with him is because he
really was willing to go all in on every
[ __ ] lie they've ever [ __ ] told
like and not only not only going all in
but he was willing to build the entire
party the entire administration the
entire country around all these [ __ ]
lies because you know before that
republicans would only go up to a
certain point right like they always
thin bailed their fascism with with
conservatism and when it was obama it
was the tea party and we don't want
debts and all this [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
all fascism
like uh you know i harp on liz cheney
here everyone's like oh she's gonna save
democracy i'm like that's fine don't
take the shovel out of her hand when
she's digging trumpism's grave i'm good
with that but we need to watch and make
sure she doesn't turn that shovel around
on us because she wants her party back
so that she can sell the thin bell
fascism through conservatism again
because she sees where this road is
headed where democrats like you and
strata just like you are going to take
advantage of the wackadoos out there
having control of their messaging in
their party like matt gatz and marjorie
taylor green jesus christ matt gatz
is is being federally investigated for
[ __ ]
sex trafficking minors and their parties
like yeah sure he's on committees yeah
sure he can question the fbi yeah sure
we want him in charge of messaging
that's a good idea let's put the let's
put the [ __ ] chomo in in charge as a
[ __ ] messaging let's do that that's
what they're doing and i can't even i
can't even [ __ ] understand how
democrats on the hill or anyone else out
there
really is so focused on each line item
issue in the buildback better which
don't even get me started on how
ridiculous um the messaging is around
bill back better why we didn't just call
in an education bill and start there and
let the republicans fight out all the
[ __ ] that's in it right it tried to tell
the american people why they don't want
all the [ __ ] that they want that's in it
just call it an education bill but
that's neither here nor there but it
just it's so frustrating that not only
the like we were talking about the
people on the hill or the democratic
machine whatever you want to call it but
it's it's not only that it's it's it's
we got to get to the minds into the
hearts of these voters and get them to
understand that like you said do you
want your family to turn into breakfast
narcs is that what you want do you want
them to go down this road where you're
you're looking around the corner looking
around your shoulder because that's what
happens in authoritarianism they don't
they don't just control sorts of things
they control
all of it and that's the whole point of
it that's why they want to seize power
so centrally they are not the majority
in this country of ideology i don't
believe that do you believe that
oh yo i mean here we know what we know
right right i mean here we go two ways
right we ask people are you you know
what's your ideology and they
self-report it and almost you know ever
in the democratic side especially modal
answer is moderate republican party
modal answer is conservative so there
you go right there's ideology difference
there in asymmetry
um and number two
republicans are much more much more
proud to say [ __ ] yeah i'm very
conservative okay and and liberals
actually have doubled the amount because
like polarization is asymmetrical it's
way worse on the right but it is there's
things that move on the left okay
and we've seen a doubling of the number
of people who are willing to say i'm
very liberal in the last decade in that
data okay so like there is like a
backlash or a like uh you know
they move we move effect going on but
generally speaking most people don't
have an ideology because they don't give
a [ __ ] and that's what you need to have
an ideology right the swing voters like
this big focus group frank let's just
put out today right like that i mean i
don't even need to hold a [ __ ] focus
group to tell you the results of that
focus group and it's gonna be you can
see this in the data and that's why you
know having voter file data is so
powerful independents are the people
that are most likely to receive their
turnout in this
midterm they of all the people who
collapse turnout in order
independents democrats then republicans
republicans don't collapse turnout not
because they're smarter or richer or
better people than us guys that's
because they have a better electoral
system and it makes sure that their
coalition
end of that system is always well
invested and well built out ours is
completely haphazard and only now coming
onto line in any regard when you look at
the virgin or georgia senate races so um
you know they have a better system
they're getting better outcomes they're
so they're over represented in terms of
power because especially these off-year
elections which is why tony and i keep
talking about outrage right you've got
to stay [ __ ] pissed and be pissed at
the right people which is not goddamn
joe biden who's governing in an
extraordinary time against opposition
that has no incentive to make policy
getting more [ __ ] done than you could
ever imagine in the situation that he's
in with only the 50 votes in the senate
which is because he's not going to get
help from republicans here because their
goal in 2022 is to make him look like
he's feeble old and he can't he can't do
government right like that's the whole
point and democrats are the only ones
that can actually [ __ ] govern like in
in the modern history the only
the only [ __ ] party that has ever
came into government and american people
have been better off while and after
they've been in power is the [ __ ]
democrats and the reason why it's really
simple it's not hard to understand they
actually want to do policy and they want
to govern so if policy is what you want
if you want you know this policy that
policy you want this [ __ ] to change you
really you really need to look at deep
down inside you and say well is an
authoritarian type party who wants one
person in charge who wants a dictator
possibly to have a fascist state or do
you want people who are pro-democracy or
who are willing to actually do the hard
because it's [ __ ] hard work it ain't
easy to do policy it is not because we
do not [ __ ] agree and and you know
everyone says that's a downfall to the
democratic party that oh their coalition
is made up of so many different people
i'm like that's the good part like what
are you talking about we're
we're [ __ ] huge our coalition is
[ __ ] huge we could bury these people
in mountains of votes every single
election if we just had the strategic
outrage we just stayed pissed every
single [ __ ] cycle and we go [ __ ]
vote because frankly at this point
democrats are the only ones that deliver
in this country for democracy and
republicans want to destroy democracy so
what is your choice i guess that's where
i fall on it no [ __ ] and let me just
tell you one more thing too like there's
this perception and people read
political science literature we write
literature in poly slide that goes into
journals and it's peer reviewed to be
kind of
absolutist-ish about its findings so
people say okay well the republicans
have an ideological coalition and
they're rallied around ideology and
democrats are group group interested and
i'm of course i'm the person who teaches
you that right right that's [ __ ] true
guys but that doesn't mean that
democrats have no ideology and and
republicans have no factionalism what
republicans did after the tea party took
over now granted like some of this rolls
into like those people seizing control
of the party is that they just decided
you know at some point they're just
gonna lay it all out and be like [ __ ]
policy right we are organized to keep
you safe from democrats that is our
coalition right so like all the
coalitions of republican politics might
care about [ __ ] but the thing they care
about above every [ __ ] thing else is
killing us
right
own the libs own the libs well i mean
it's been it's been it's become their
entire uh political identity yeah and
and no we listen tony we can [ __ ] about
that right i mean
so like i want to be [ __ ] really
clear about something because i
took on dissertation on polarization
because i committed i feel all the feels
that people feel on the left about this
[ __ ] okay i want to be really clear
about that but at the end of the day
guys when your other the other system is
going to hit us right um you know in the
local paper here for the competitive
race here in oregon for the one of the
gop nominee who ran last time saying he
said i don't give a [ __ ] who th who the
nominee is it could be moderate more
moderate progressive vel
hoyle or it could be someone from the
far left doesn't matter because i'm
going to brand them all the same i'm
going to make them own their shitty
party that's literally what the quote
says right that's branding and that is
what i am arguing we need to be doing
and if we are failing to fill that
atmosphere if we're defending [ __ ] if
we're explaining [ __ ]
oh no we don't really feel like that or
the policy doesn't really do that we're
gonna [ __ ] lose okay so like let's
separate the policy argument
the inclination to get on tv and give
substantive deep like really like
sincere answers because we have to
[ __ ] win we have to win so get on
there and when they ask you about
failing buildback better then you you
bring up repeal and replace right pivot
and attack right talk about [ __ ]
failures they ran off
right and still couldn't get it done
couldn't get it done if i'm so bad and
i'll be like you want to ask me about
buildback better after i pass you know
blah blah blah blah blah blah when these
[ __ ] can't even repeal and
replace obamacare when they made it
their entire [ __ ] platform for a day
right well [ __ ]
they not only try to repeal or replace
they tried to destroy it through the
supreme court they tried to destroy it
with executive orders they undermined it
and caused people to die we've never
[ __ ] replaced them to check for that
all i'm saying tony is trying to send
some [ __ ] checks
we don't have to worry about what
they're going to do next they've done
enough guys and they made benghazi the
key issue of an election cycle four
[ __ ] years after the event okay
it happened in 2012. right
we have we have some comments here that
i want to show you um yoda says oh my
god rachel bittikoffer i am fangirling
out now
uh and mj says hi rachel um i want
rachel sake politics girl and porter to
run the world
yeah let's do that let's get let's get
let's get rachel and and katie porter's
white board together and let's see let's
see how they [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
let's go right pivot and attack right
right
so so we do have we do have one uh uh
kind of a question here we need to get
uh to reach out to younger generations
millennials and gen z um you know that's
that's one thing like
that's one thing that they never do like
they don't ever divide up their
electorate like oh well we need to reach
out to older folks we need to reach out
like they're just like no we're going to
reach out to everyone and we're going to
try to we're going to try to get them to
believe in the [ __ ] we believe and like
you said we're going to get them to own
the libtards right like that's their
whole thing we don't we we can reach out
to millennials we can reach out to gen z
but it doesn't have to be like a focused
it just can be strategic outrage
throughout the whole freaking map we can
stay pissed we can go vote and we can
make sure that our message speaks to all
americans not just one not just this one
you know i think that's sometimes when
they have the challenges you know
they're they're dancing around these
issues um and trying to figure out the
exact line item in the bill that they're
gonna support when they get become
congress well [ __ ] go be a member of
congress first and then sort out the
[ __ ] line item that you want in the
bill for your constituents
and republicans do because they don't
have a policy they don't have any what
do they [ __ ] run on what is it taking
away people's liberty i mean come on
they don't have [ __ ] policies i mean
repeal and replace right they could
never do that they had never had a plan
because the obamacare package the aca is
their [ __ ] man
right it is their bill right it's their
bill like we forgot that like it's been
so many years that we forget that mitt
romney mitt romney with the help of ted
kennedy passed that bill in
massachusetts and then they're like
obama's like copy [ __ ] paste that's
what i'm saying why couldn't obama just
once have been like [ __ ] it's your bill
well well if you go back if you go back
as far as the 2008 campaign between john
mccain and and barack obama really if
you look at the aca and you compare it
to what those two candidates were
campaigning on that [ __ ] aca plan
looks more like what the hell john
mccain was talking about than what the
[ __ ] obama was talking about during the
campaign it looks way more like what
because it's here
right exactly exactly i mean this is
literally like a private sector i mean
it's the per i mean actually you know
what it's not the best for health
options it's better than the the
previous system right right but at the
end of the [ __ ] day like it there's
no
uh there's no way to do health care
reform that's more private sector
friendly right right
and we killed we lost the messaging on
that you should have seen that i'm not
going to tell you guys who this was but
it was a pretty important person with a
lot of like influencer top-down framing
ability
and you know i suggested i said why
didn't you guys just run on obamacare it
[ __ ] insured 30 million people and
then they didn't die right so just find
a couple that didn't die and make some
ads
and like it had never [ __ ] occurred
to them like oh if they run against
obamacare and pick out the [ __ ]
website to harp on and then we get
defensive
then we lose right right because we're
fighting we're fighting in the space of
the website sucks and that has nothing
to do with the bill right no doubt and
like they and then they go and they
figure out like eventually over time and
it's just so painful to be me right so
like they figure out over time finally
oh turns out when you ask people about
the individual components they like it
they don't like that [ __ ] right
and they don't like it because it's
called obamacare well you know that's
why they the [ __ ] republicans named
it obamacare if you want to [ __ ] kill
a gop policy name it the trump tax plan
right right right right right right yeah
like i just i you know at the end of the
day
they make their fortune right they
wanted they knew clinton was likely to
be the nominee in 16. they knew that
after getting disrupted by obama there's
no way the party's going to do it twice
to her right she's in 60
approval secretary of state killing the
[ __ ] job it's two years after
benghazi okay right and that's when they
were like [ __ ] we've got to figure it
out we're gonna we're gonna and she put
that [ __ ] to bed she put the benghazi
[ __ ] and it doesn't even matter right
like they did eight nine ten whatever
select committees until they found that
[ __ ] email
right and now we like you know i mean oh
i just i i could forgive the media less
about like apparently sleeping on the
lead context that in half of the
republican party at the state level at
all of the federal levels in the
judicial system of the doj
conspired to steal the election and they
were only thwarted by luck basically
right and like there's no conversation
about that but we [ __ ] know
everything about clinton's private set i
could tell you everything you want to
know about that private server store
well i mean and that's what they do i
mean they're still bitching about
hillary clinton on fox news they still
[ __ ] about a certain person's laptop i
mean literally the the former
president's son
is on a [ __ ] cocaine bender
posting videos about how he's going to
take over the world and how they're
going to take over the world and [ __ ]
hunter biden is nowhere to be found
republicans are paying 2 000 to take a
[ __ ] picture with booger sugar junior
yeah right
no democrat in the [ __ ] country is
lining up to meet hunter biden not
[ __ ] one of them not one of them but
they keep harping on it they're obsessed
with dr fauci this is the [ __ ] that they
do and i'm and i think
i'm saying it and you're saying it this
is the [ __ ] we can do we don't have to
use misinformation and [ __ ] lies it's
really easy when it's right out in front
of you you have like you said you have
these [ __ ] wackadoo criminals running
the republican party why in the [ __ ]
can't we go hey look at them all the
republicans are just like them if they
got an r next to the name that's who the
[ __ ] they are that's what they want
let's pin them up like the guy what what
uh make them own their own [ __ ] party
right make them own it make them [ __ ] no
[ __ ] and then when you fail to [ __ ]
do that then you end up with a beltway
narrative of how oh well look at yunkan
he won't let trump come to virginia so
therefore he's rejecting trump no dude
he's got half the [ __ ] guy's platform
he's giving lip service to election you
know um you know his election conspiracy
[ __ ] before the election even happens so
like basically prepping his loss right
right so he's obviously not a democrat
small d democrat because you don't
[ __ ] do that
right you believe in democracy and then
he gets into office and what's the first
thing he does he goes full [ __ ] ron
desantis and all i wanted to do in
virginia six months out it's like look
this is what's going to be like what
what the fall will look like we've got
the crt thing coming down
let's [ __ ] hammer
this theme that young can this is not
change that you want republican change
in 22 21 in virginia 22 here is not the
change you
voter it could be fill in the blank
voter is going are going to want because
it is going to wreck havoc on your
economics on your health on your kids
future right and whatever else is you
know a perfectly or especially pertinent
to that voter right but you can't
make it
it can't just ignore
this giant you know uh aspect of it and
and and pretend i hope it's just gonna
go away
well i really appreciate you coming
we've had we've had about a 30 minute
conversation i think i took more your
your your time than i had asked for so i
appreciate you coming on you are welcome
back every single week any any time that
you want just just send me a message say
hey i got something i want to talk about
and we'll get on here and we'll rant and
rave and we can go after these folks and
maybe we can teach some people how to
how to frame up the messaging because
literally we are in a situation where
democrats are the only party that are
going to deliver democracy in this
country like you said in virginia um
california thank god that recall
happened the way we needed it to but
2022 is gonna be important because
democrats are the only one that wants to
deliver democracy republicans want to
destroy it so we have to stay pissed we
have to go [ __ ] vote and the way that
we get out the vote and pile up
mountains and mountains of ballots on
top of these son of a [ __ ] and fascist
is that we have to have strategic
outrage and we have to stay
in that mindset so rachel where where
can everyone find you at um on twitter
and and strike back tell them real quick
before we before we let you go where do
they find you so they can start this
process of learning what that strategic
outrage is yeah you follow me on on
twitter at rachel biddehoffer and um
go to strike pack check out our ads some
of these ads are all the ads are
teaching ads basically i mean they get
deployed or they'll be deployed in ways
too but they're also designed to teach
people like this is how the gop does
their messaging they don't they don't
they aren't looking at the voter file
and say oh there's a base mobilization
pool and a persuasion pool and we should
argue about policy that's popular that
pull tests well with that persuasion
pool like that's not how the gop runs
their messaging they don't run their
targeting the same way either at the end
of the day the deployment of elect of
these electoral tactics and we want um
you know people to learn about more
about that they can read my article in
salon about it too that kind of breaks
down those ads and explains how they're
performing that that function of
modernizing our messaging approach
well thank you rachel i appreciate you
joining us everyone stay stay with us we
will go to the [ __ ] list roundup right
after this break thanks rachel
you sit your ass down sit the flip down
we're not finished the tony michaels
podcast we'll be right back
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to